the world needs the positive explosion
[Music]
and we came with dynamite
and boom um
well i bet you guys missed your fans
because i know your fans missed you and
thankfully
you guys are going to be performing at
the vmas you're performing dynamite for
the first time
uh what can fans expect from that
performance
foreign
what was your favorite part about
filming that video
it's the first song you guys have ever
done all in english right
what was that like it was a huge
enormous challenge for all of us um
well but you know we but we decided to
do it because you know
let's try something new let's challenge
something in this current situation
you know pandemic so every i think
everyone did well
quite well when we first listened to the
demo we just loved it and you know
let's keep it this way and we've done
we've done it you know you guys said
that dynamite brings some much needed
energy
into the world how did everything that's
going on in the world
including with the pandemic kind of
influence your new music and your
upcoming album like what's the
inspiration behind the new music
you know 2020 has been truly a rough
year for
many and there were many surprises
changes we felt like
desperate to be honest with you um we
needed
we thought we needed a breakthrough from
that so we focused on
what we can do the best and that was the
music
and the performance you know and we
tried to get energy and
we wanted to give the energy back to the
world so you know
things are simple the world needs the
positive explosion
and we came with dynamite and boom
you're right it's so needed right now
and i got to tell you guys you know
you guys influenced the army in so many
ways
and including outside of your music and
so many of your fans have become
activists
on social media standing up for their
own beliefs what message you have for
the army
for your fans who are really doing their
part to make the world a better place
foreign
[Music]
thank you
i know you guys had to cancel your world
tour because of the coronavirus pandemic
what did you guys do during that time uh
work on new music
yeah music play guitar sleeping netflix
drawing painting watching netflix
watching yes watching netflix i was
watching you guys on youtube
how much did you guys miss each other
did you get to see each other a lot
during that break
always we always always 24 7. every day
so you guys have your map of the soul 1
concert coming up how will this
performance compare to your past tours
for now we don't know it's uh it's
whether it's going like both on and
offline or
just the online but you know things many
things have changes so
you know we'll see we we hope to um see
the fans like eye to eye face to face in
in the place but you know we'll see and
we don't know but
you know if um even though the concert
goes just in online
and we'll do our best and the dynamite
will
explode with break the silence the movie
obviously fans are going to get to see
you guys up close and personal again
raise your hand if you cry in the movie
no
[Laughter]
amazing well thank you guys so much i'm
going to take a quick selfie
on my phone right everyone look at the
camera everyone look ready
stay safe yes stay safe